hey youtubers is Charlie a lot of
spider-man homecoming hype happening
right now people going crazy about
getting carnage into the new movies so
I'm gonna explain what's going on in a
general history for his character in the
comics and on the ultimate spider-man TV
show there's a couple different versions
of him in surprise surprise he actually
debuted around the time Deadpool debuted
so a bunch of people are talking about
carnage being in the new spider-man Sony
Marvel films and even though it's you
know too late to get him into spider-man
homecoming there's a trilogy so there's
plenty of room for other versions of the
symbiote and carnage just to explain who
he is is basically like a spin-off
version of the Venom symbiote so if you
guys haven't ever seen it there's
actually an ultimate spider-man cartoon
on Disney XD where they've done a bunch
of different versions of the characters
including anti-venom which is like a
whole other thing but it's very
different from the comics so what I'm
going to do is I'm going to explain who
carnage is his story in the comics some
of the big storylines if you really want
to read a carnage story because they're
actually trying to do some really cool
stuff with him in the dark hole which
gets into agents of shield and stuff
that's happening on TV now so he's like
very present in what's happening with
the spider-man character in movies and
TV even if it's a long shot that we
would see him in a movie and I think the
big reason why lin-manuel wants to play
carnage and I think he's referring to
the Cletus Kasady like the crazy insane
version of carnage from the comics is
just because it's such an interesting
spin on a character that you don't
normally see in big movies like this so
the crazier actors get to be in movies
the more fun it tends to be for them so
like a really good example of that is
Tom Hiddleston who plays Loki really
amazing performance that he's had in the
Marvel Universe so far but when they
were originally casting that first Thor
movie he went to like his friend Kenneth
Branagh who was directing the movie in
asked him about reading for Thor and he
was like no no no you don't want to play
Thor you want to play Loki it'll be way
more fun for you
we always were putting our chips on Loki
we believed in him as a character had
Tom not brought him to life in a way the
audience responded to it probably
wouldn't gone anywhere you know at first
Tom was up for Thor he trained he came
in he was ripped you know swinging the
hammer the brain he did a tremendous job
but he wasn't Thor the moment he came in
and read though who was Loki you're my
son I wanted only to protect you from
the truth well because I I'm the monster
parents tell their children about at
night you know it all makes sense now
why are you favored for all these years
because they're matter how much you
claim to love me give it an hour frost
giant sitting on the throne of Asgard so
that's like a whole other story because
there actually is like a screen test of
Tom Hiddleston dressed like Thor
auditioning for Thor but as we know he
ended up going for Loki he slimmed down
and became one of the best villains
Marvel's ever had so I think that's why
people want to play a lot of crazy
villains in the Marvel Universe carnage
literally being insane like he is
actually certified crazy most of the
villains in the Marvel Universe are
normal people they go crazy but the
whole idea behind the carnage character
is that part of the Venom symbiote which
is already up you know pretty evil thing
by itself
who gets bonded to a person who is
legitimately insane like venom Bond's to
Eddie Brock he just has a big beef
against spider-man and it just heightens
some of his more violent tendencies but
imagine the Venom symbiote bonded to
someone who was already a really bad
serial killer in a maximum-security
prison
which as a little kid was my first
encounter with the character so just to
start with comic book carnage I'll
explain the ultimate spider-man version
of carnage too because that's kind of a
blend of a bunch of different storylines
and arcs from the spider-man comics so
way back in the early 90s like pretty
close to when the time deadpool debuted
carnage debuted this is the time in
marvel comics when they're getting super
hardcore so of course you have like two
of the craziest characters in their
history debuting but eddie brock is
currently a prisoner in Rikers Island
prison he does not have the Venom
symbiote he's been separated for it
that's why he's locked up otherwise he'd
break out instantly if he had the
symbiote but as the symbiote begins
run free it eventually makes its way to
Rikers where Eddie Brock is his cellmate
Cletus Kasady also gets bonded to a
piece of it and becomes the carnage
character killing a guard escaping going
on a rampage so that was about a year
between the time Cletus Kasady first
appeared as like Eddie Brock's cellmate
in Rikers Island prison in when he
actually took on the carnage persona so
the way they explained carnage is that
the Venom symbiote when it was trying to
rescue Eddie Brock inside Rikers said
that it was pregnant which is like a
crazy idea but you have to remember this
is the early 90s so when they did it on
the ultimate spider-man cartoon they
actually turned it into this Green
Goblin plot where he makes a special
version of the Venom symbiote he tries
to inject Peter Parker with it turning
him into carnage
so TV carnage has like a slightly more
believable origin story but comic-book
cletus kasady carnage is just a super
deep cut so it's always fun to see what
Marvel does with the character so he's
been around for a long time but carnage
was just meant to be like the uber
version of venom like spider-man has a
lot of big battles with the Venom
symbiote it's very powerful it's bonded
to someone who's mostly they're all up
top but you have to imagine like if the
Venom symbiote bonded to someone who was
just completely insane the horrors that
they would unleash so just like the
things that the carnage symbiote would
do were just so much freakier than venom
but the powers of the symbiote are
actually relatively malleable like it
really just depends on the person that
it's bonded to so venom could do this
stuff too it's just that he's not that
crazy so originally in the comics
carnage debuts and he's this villain
this is so over the top spider-man can't
defeat him by himself so the twist as
you would imagine is that he needs the
help of Eddie Brock venom to take down
this new symbiote because the only thing
that venom hates more than spider-man
right now is this new symbiote so they
team up take carnage down and then go
back to being enemies
so on the spider-man animated TV show
there are actually two versions of the
carnage character the first one was a
variation on the Venom symbiote that
Norman Osborn tried to inject Peter
Parker with you know for a brief time he
became carnage
then a couple seasons later in season
four they did a symbiote saga storyline
it was kind of a blend of a couple
different spider-man arcs including
maximum carnage in Spider Island maximum
carnage was just a storyline where
carnage in a couple years after he
debuted in the comics broke out of an
insane asylum
again recruited his own version of the
sinister six and went on like a mass
killing spree in the city
that a bunch of Heroes including
spider-man and venom had a team-up to
stop him
Spider Island was a storyline that
involved the anti-venom that helped cure
this spider virus that was turning
people into like mutated giant spiders
so they kind of combined those arcs for
the ultimate spider-man cartoon to do
their symbiote storyline which was
basically like a three-part story so you
have the carnage symbiote that debuts
you need anti-venom to take them down
anti-venom is like a completely separate
idea it's basically a mutated version of
the original Venom symbiote that bonds
with Eddie Brock's white blood cells and
becomes a symbiote capable of healing
any disease so they use it to cure this
giant spider virus that's turning
everybody into giant man spiders so
really like one of the biggest
differences between the carnage symbiote
in the Venom symbiote is that venom
needs a host to bond to in order to you
know take physical form the carnage
symbiote does not need that now you have
to remember it's the offspring of the
Venom symbiote so it's a little bit
different it's not like an exact copy
but it's just meant to be like the
freaky craziest possible version you
could imagine of the Venom symbiote so
they might choose to do spider virus or
you know version of Spider Island or a
venom story arc in the new movies but
it'll take them a long time to get to
carnage because you kind of have to do
the Venom symbiote first in Sony was
originally planning a venom spin-off
spider-man movie before they made the
deal with Marvel so that's all kind of
up in the air now like they were going
to make a sinister six movie but this
was during Andrew Garfield era so
they're still doing that stuff but it's
kind of been back-burnered because of
the new spider-man homecoming trilogy so
what I think they'll probably do is
slowly weave in the idea of venom in the
spider-man movies eventually and then
just kind of try and do it off as a
separate thing
it just depends on what the tone of
these spider-man movies are going to be
because he's going to be in high school
for the duration of his new trilogy I
really think that venom carnage is
better left for like super early phase
five if it's going to be a Marvel joint
but it almost seems like it would be
easier for them if they were to do what
they were originally planning on doing
and just do venom as a separate thing
and then introduce carnage during that
story life because carnage is really a
twist on a venom idea so those two
characters just go hand-in-hand and I
just love the idea that there's somebody
that venom hates more than Peter Parker
but the big twist of the spider-man
homecoming movie this first movie is
that all these kids are in high school
and you have characters that will
eventually become Hobgoblin you have
Flash Thompson who himself became venom
space knight eventually like one of the
hosts of the Venom symbiote and they all
just seem like super buddies so you just
know that something terrible has to
happen between them eventually but let
me know in the comments how do you think
that Sony and Marvel would choose to do
the venom and carnage characters do you
think that we'll ever see them in the
main Marvel films that they're making or
do you think that they'll try to just do
spin-off movies by themselves
so there are a couple other Marvel
videos that I want to do this weekend
they're teasing a brand new inhuman on
agents of shield like a new mystery
inhuman so I'll probably do a video for
that in Kevin Feige just confirmed the
Captain Marvel is going to be the most
powerful character good character that
they've ever done now like we've seen
Odin we've seen Dormammu we've seen
Thanos so there are also other super
powerful characters but I think he was
talking mostly about heroes that are
going to be getting their own solo
spin-off movies so that Captain Marvel
video will probably be next so I'll post
that in a little while while you guys
wait for that to post you can click here
for that funny spider-man Tom Holland
video and you can click here for the
latest like huge trailer for the flash
for night crossover thank you so much
for watching everybody let's high five
I'll see you guys tonight
you